[Music]
kind of like a skater has a skateboarder
BMX and advice I just saw the wheel
turns on fun so why not take it in the
park
a man wheels bothering him and I ride
wcm a WCM X stands for wheelchair
motocross it's you know taking your
chair into the skate park and hitting
ramp kind of the same thing as BMX or
the wheelchair I first started going to
the skate parks when I was 8 years old
and I've been doing it for 16 years now
the wheelchair is definitely just an
extension of my body because skaters
aren't always on their skateboard and
bikers aren't always on the bike but I'm
always on my chair so that gives me like
an unfair advantage to just practice
everywhere I go I feel like I'm lucky
that I always have my wheelchair with me
because I can just jump whenever I want
I was born with spina bifida I've had 21
surgeries throughout my life and I spent
a lot of time in the hospitals and yeah
it would be easy to just be bummed out
on that but I was for me I just found
the positive the wheelchairs just always
been fun and it's wheels stuck to your
butt how's that not a great time in 2008
I got the Guinness world record for the
first backflip on a wheelchair now is
that a local competition here in Vegas
called Amgen
pretty cool dish one of my favorite
tricks is just simple handful because I
always loved watching skaters do it when
I was growing up and you know watching
the pros do it it's just something I
wanted to learn I'm very blessed to be
able to do what I love and what I'm
passionate about for a living a lot of
the time the wheelchair comes with the
stereotype of you can't do this or
whatever because of the medical device I
developed in the wheelchair is a great
opportunity